bonjour à tous
on va pas
l'expérience de milgram stanley milgram
est un psychologue américain né en 1933
et mort en 1984 il est principalement
connu pour la série d'expériences qu'il
a entreprise entre 1960 et 1963 qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui sous le nom d'
expérience de milgram
cette expérience avait pour but
principal de montrer la tendance de
l'être humain notamment de l'être humain
social à la soumission à l'autorité
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui
connaît cette expérience on en trouve
des références dans la culture populaire
il existe même un film dans lequel cette
expérience est reproduite le film i
comme icare d'henri verneuil sorti en
1979 et dont vous pourrez trouver
facilement des extraits sur internet
dans cette vidéo on va non seulement
présenter cette expérience décrire le
protocole de milgram ainsi que les
résultats qu'il a obtenus
mais on va aussi proposer une
interprétation de cette expérience
une interprétation qui sera à
contre-courant des interprétations
classiques et comme sur cette chaîne on
n'est pas là pour trouver la vérité
mais pour donner matière à penser eh
bien on va essayer de pousser un petit
peu la réflexion sur cette expérience
pour tenter de voir ce qu'elle nous dit
l'expérience de milgram a pour but
d'évaluer le degré d'obéissance d'un
individu à une autorité plus exactement
et vous verrez que c'est important de
faire la précision à une autorité perçu
comme légitime
on parle alors de soumission la
soumission désignant ici
une action qui va contre la conscience
morale de l'individu la soumission se
caractérise par le fait qu'il y ait un
conflit moral
un conflit entre l'action réalisée par
le sujet et sa conscience morale qui lui
interdit de faire cette action
sa conscience morale qui s'opposent à
son acte
donc même si je pense que vous êtes déjà
très nombreux à connaître le principe de
l'expérience de milgram
on va quand même prendre le temps de
faire un rappel et d'expliquer en quoi
consiste précisément cette expérience
un laboratoire scientifique publie une
annonce un appel à participer à une
expérience scientifique sur
l'apprentissage on explique que le but
de cette expérience c'est d'évaluer
l'efficacité de certaines méthodes dans
la mémorisation et dans l'apprentissage
donc une fois que les participants se
sont manifestés il entre dans le
laboratoire par groupe de deux donc
chaque expérience implique deux
participants de participants qui entre
dans la salle d'expérience et qui sont
reçus par une équipe de scientifiques de
scientifiques en blouse blanche c'est à
dire portant les attributs de leur
autorité et à ce moment là on effectue
un tirage au sort entre les deux
participants pour répartir les rôles
pour désigner le rôle que chacun des
deux participants va remplir durant
l'expérience à l'issue du tirage au sort
l'un des participants est désigné élèves
et l'autre est désigné professeur
à ce moment là on installe l'élève sur
une chaise électrique dans une pièce
distincte du professeur et le professeur
quant à lui est placé devant un pupitre
qui contient une liste de mots à dicter
à l'élève pour qui les retiennent
et donc le but du jeu c'est que l'élève
doit retenir doit mémoriser un maximum
des mots de la liste et à chaque erreur
le professeur aura le devoir de lui
envoyer une décharge électrique
alors au début il s'agit d'une des
charges assez légères et plus les
erreurs seront nombreuses plus les
décharges seront puissantes
c'est à dire qu'à chaque erreur la
décharge électrique augmente de 15 volts
pour finir avec la décharge maximale
d'environ 400 volts en 400 volts je peux
vous dire que vous le sentez pas c'est
quand on met les doigts dans la prise
électrique
on risque du 220 volts donc là on est
quasiment sûr le double dans cette
expérience peut avoir un côté amusant au
départ le fait de jouer des rôles
le rôle du professeur le rôle de l'élève
et sauf que au bout d'un certain nombre
d'erreurs et donc au bout d'un certain
nombre de décharges électriques envoyé à
l'élève
le professeur se rend bien compte que
l'élève commencent à souffrir on se rend
bien compte que le mal qu'il lui inflige
est réel d'autant que l'élève exprime sa
douleur d'abord par des gémissements
puis par des cris et à la fin par des
supplications
supplie les scientifiques de mettre un
terme à l'expérience et le problème
c'est que le scientifique qui se tient
aux côtés du professeur lui demande de
continuer
et lui demande de continuer il lui
interdit même d'arrêter l'expérience et
c'est à ce moment là que le sujet
professeurs commencent à entrer dans un
conflit moral
il rentre dans un conflit moral parce
qu'il voit bien que ce qu'il est en
train de faire n'est pas normal il a
conscience que le rôle d'une expérience
scientifique ne devrait pas être de
faire souffrir un laboratoire
scientifique n'est pas censé être un
lieu de torture
et c'est justement pour cette raison
c'est justement parce qu'un laboratoire
scientifique n'est pas un lieu de
torture que le sujet est incité à
continuer à chaque fois que le
professeur hésitant voyez la décharge
suivante le scientifique le regarde dans
les yeux et lui dit poursuivaient
plus exactement le scientifique répond à
la première hésitation du professeur en
lui disant veuillez continuer s'il vous
plaît
lorsque le sujet exprime une deuxième
fois son désir d'arrêter l'expérience
le scientifique lui dit alors
l'expérience exige que vous continuiez
donc on voit bien que sur le plan de la
formulation de la phrase il ya un palier
qui est franchie en termes d'expression
de l'autorité en termes d'expression de
la contrainte
au bout de la troisième fois le
scientifique répond il est absolument
indispensable que vous continuiez là
encore un nouveau cap est franchi dans
la rhétorique de l'obéissance pour
arriver à la 4è phrase du scientifique
vous n'avez pas le choix vous devez
continuer
alors ils se trouvent je fais une petite
parenthèse mais ça aura son importance
pour la suite que dans cette expérience
il y à différents paramètres variables
et parmi ces paramètres variables
notamment la distance entre l'enseignant
et l'élève
il se trouve que la proximité physique
favorise l'empathie alors qu'au
contraire la distance favorise le
détachement
si vous préférez il est plus facile
d'infliger des souffrances un inconnu
lorsqu'on est physiquement à distance
un autre paramètre variable dans
l'expérience c'est le degré de cohérence
entre les scientifiques c'est-à-dire
entre les représentants de l'autorité
par exemple si au sein de l'équipe des
scientifiques qui chapote l'expérience
l'un d'eux manifeste son souhait
d'arrêter l'expérience et que s'engage
alors un conflit au sein de l'autorité
et bien systématiquement on constate que
le professeur arrête l'expérience
à partir du moment où apparaît une
faille dans la cohérence entre les
représentants de l'autorité
cette autorité s'effondre
et donc à la fin de l'expérience on
révèle le pot-aux-roses
on révèle aux professeurs que le but
véritable de l'expérience n'était pas de
tester des méthodes d'apprentissage mais
que le véritable but de l'expérience
c'est ed évaluer son degré d'obéissance
à l'autorité c'était lui le sujet de
l'évaluation scientifique
par ce qui est amusant c'est que dans
les rapports qui ont été faits de cette
expérience on indique que le moment de
la révélation de la vérité le moment où
en informe le professeur que c'était lui
le cobaye de l'expérience il ya cette
révélation est censé le rassurer
pourquoi le rassurer bien parce que ça
signifie qu'en réalité l'élève était un
comédien il ne lui a donc infligé aucune
souffrance
c'est ça qui est sensé de rassurer
finalement je n'ai rien fait de mal se
dira t-il mais j'ai pas ce que vous en
pensez mais personnellement je suis pas
sûr que cette révélation soit de nature
à le rassurer
parce qu'en même temps qu'on lui révèle
qu'il n'a infligé aucune torture à ce
pauvre élèves ont lu faire maintenant
savoir qu'il a accepté le principe
d'envoyer des décharges électriques
un innocent parce qu'il avait donné des
mauvaises réponses autrement dit on le
rassure en lui disant qu'il ne lui a
causé aucune douleur mais on le
traumatise en lui mettant souvenez sa
culpabilité
on le met face à la réalité de ses actes
si bien qu'on pourrait se demander
d'ailleurs qui de tout ce petit monde et
le plus sadique
est ce que c'est le professeur qui
envoie des décharges électriques ou est
ce que c'est le scientifique qui cachent
au professeur la nature réelle de ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire
dans les faits on observe que le taux
d'obéissance moyens à cette expérience
est d'environ 65% alors c'est un chiffre
qu'il faut considérablement relativiser
parce que ça dépend des variables ça
dépend des paramètres qui ont été
choisis pour chaque expérience parce que
le tableau récapitulatif de l'expérience
nous apprend qu'en cas de contact
physique entre le professeur et l'élève
le taux d'obéissance tombe à 30 % et
plus encore quand il y à des ordres
contradictoires au sein de l'équipe
scientifique
le taux d'obéissance chute carrément à
0%
donc on voit bien à quel point la
cohérence au sein des représentants de
l'autorité est absolument primordial
dans l'obéissance du sujet
et dans tous les cas on retiendra que
tous les participants absolument tous
les participants ont manifesté des
signes de réticences
des signes de réticences qui pouvait
aller de la simple question est ce que
je dois continuer est ce qu'il est
normal que l'élève est aussi mal à la
protestation voir à l'interruption pure
et simple de l'expérience
donc déjà ça permet de voir qu'il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de psychopathe dans
l'eau
et ça on reçoit ses déclarations
et pourquoi je dis ça et bien justement
parce que j'aimerais maintenant aborder
le sujet des commentaires qui ont été
faits à propos de cette expérience et
notamment le commentaire de milgram
lui-même
milgram a qualifié les résultats de son
expérience d'inquiétant
et c'est d'ailleurs l'idée qu'on
retrouve la plupart du temps dans
l'opinion publique c'est à dire que
quand on demande à une personne qui a
connaissance de cette expérience ce
qu'elle pense des résultats bien la
plupart des personnes disent la même
chose
que c'est inquiétant
que ça révèle à quel point l'être humain
est soumis à quel point l'être humain
obéit à l'autorité au point d'occulter
totalement ce que lui dit sa conscience
c'est ça le commentaire le plus fréquent
sur cette expérience
en 1974 mg a cherché à comprendre les
causes de ces résultats
autrement dit il s'est intéressé aux
raisons pour lesquelles la plupart des
sujets avaient obéi aux injonctions de
l'autorité
il a donc publié un livre dans lequel il
essaie de comprendre le phénomène de la
soumission à l'autorité
et c'est là dessus que je voudrais
insister car dès qu'on parle de
l'expérience de milgram
c'est à dire d'une expérience
scientifique une expérience de
psychologie sociale
on a tendance à tomber immédiatement
dans le jugement moral on va dire que
c'est inquiétant on va même dire que
c'est scandaleux
autrement dit on va porter un jugement
de valeur sur ce résultat
alors même que le but d'une expérience
scientifique c'est d'abord de comprendre
comprendre un phénomène au lieu de le
juger
parce que lorsqu'on juge moralement le
résultat d'une expérience scientifique
bien on oublie une chose c'est que les
sujets qui envoie des décharges
électriques
c'est nous
une expérience scientifique et plus
particulièrement une expérience en
psychologie sociale
elle implique un échantillonnage est à
dire qu'on va prendre des sujets qui
sont représentatifs de la population et
donc lorsque l'on s'extrait des
résultats de cette expérience en disant
par exemple que nous nous ne l'aurions
pas fait mais c'est tout simplement faux
en tout cas statistiquement faux
la réalité c'est qu'on peut pas savoir
comment on aurait réagi on peut pas
s'auto exclure du groupe des bourreaux
sans avoir été soumis à l'expérience
parce que c'est trop facile
c'est trop facile de dire ce qu'on
aurait fait ou ce qu'on n'aurait pas
fait alors même qu'on n'a pas été dans
la situation de le faire ou de ne pas le
faire
quand on parle au conditionnel c'est
qu'on n'est pas en mesure de parler à
l'indicatif
et cette attitude qui consiste à
dénoncer à juger à s'offusquer de ce que
la plupart des personnes obéissent à
l'autorité bien c'est déjà en soi un
comportement problématique
un comportement de spectateurs
spectateurs qui distribue les bons et
les mauvais points sans essayer de
comprendre la nature du phénomène qui
est mis en évidence dans cette
expérience
comprendre ce que les résultats de cette
expérience nous dise
parce que finalement quand on dit que
nous à la place du professeur on aurait
réagi autrement qu'on aurait mis un
terme à l'expérience qu'on aurait fait
prévaloir notre conscience morale mais
quand on fait ça on fait exactement la
même chose que le cobaye qui obéit
de la même façon que le cobaye et lutte
sa responsabilité en la reportant sur
l'autorité scientifique on élude notre
propre responsabilité en la reportant
sur une affirmation qu'on est incapable
de prouver
cette expérience ne doit pas nous
conduire à juger l'être humain mais à le
comprendre
comprendre ce qui a fait que 65% des
sujets ont obéi
et donc c'est ce qu'a essayé de faire
1000 g il a étudié ce phénomène il en
arrive à la conclusion que l'obéissance
était une tendance sociale générale liée
à l'intégration dans un système
hiérarchique
l'idée c'est de dire qu'il existe dans
la plupart des groupes une hiérarchie
une hiérarchie perçu comme légitime
parce que nécessaire au fonctionnement
du groupe avec à sa tête une ou des
autorités parce qu'attention c'est très
important précisé qu'il ya une
distinction à faire entre une autorité
perçu comme légitime et notorité perçu
comme illégitime
on aura beaucoup plus de facilité à
obéir à une autorité perçu comme
légitime qu'à obéir à une autorité qu'on
ne reconnaît pas et je mets de côté le
cas de la contrainte physique
mais pour faire une analogie très simple
supposons que votre meilleur ami dans
lequel vous avez confiance vous demande
de lui rendre un service et que ce
service implique que vous fassiez
quelque chose qui vous met en danger
peut-être que vous allez refusé
peut-être que ça lui répondre non désolé
mais je ne te rendrait pas service
une chose est sûre c'est que vous allez
réfléchir
comme on dit même si vous refusez vous
accordez à votre meilleure amie
suffisamment de crédit pour prendre le
temps d'analyser sa demande
pour prendre le temps de la considérer
peut pas faire comme si ça n'avait pas
d' influence
pas faire semblant de croire que la
confiance que vous placez dans une
personne n'a aucune influence dans votre
décision de satisfaire ou pas l'une de
ces demandes
ça joue
sûr que ça joue
et bien sûr que vous aurez beaucoup plus
de facilité à satisfaire la demande de
votre meilleur ami qu'à satisfaire la
demande d'un inconnu croisé dans la rue
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
notre degré d'obéissance à une demande
quelconque est influencé par le crédit
que l'on place dans celui dont émane la
demande
un scientifique en blouse blanche qui
vous accueille dans un laboratoire qui
fait partie d'une équipe
autrement dit qui s'intègre parfaitement
dans le système hiérarchique sociale il
est normal de le considérer a priori
comme digne de confiance
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il est normal de
faire absolument tout ce qui nous
demandera bien sûr que non mais ça veut
dire qu'il est normal que cela crée un
conflit
un conflit intérieur un conflit
intérieur entre votre conscience morale
et votre certitude d'être face à une
autorité légitime
anne autorités dans laquelle vous pouvez
placer du crédit
je rappelle que crédit credo en latin ça
veut dire croire
donner du crédit ça veut dire donner des
raisons de croire
tollé des raisons de faire confiance
un scientifique qui vous demande de
poursuivre l'expérience et qui ajoute
qu'il prend toute la responsabilité des
conséquences ça vous incite à ne pas le
considérer comme un simple malade mental
qui vous demandent de torturer un
innocent
donc il est normal qu'il y ait conflit
moral conflit entre le sentiment de
faire quelque chose de mal faire
souffrir à l'innocent et la conviction
profonde qu'une autorité scientifique ne
peut pas nous demander de faire quelque
chose de cruel
parce que si on ne peut pas faire
confiance à un scientifique autrement
dit si on peut pas se fier à un
représentant légitime de l'autorité et à
ce moment là c'est notre confiance dans
les structures mêmes de la société qui
s'évapore
à ce moment là on peut plus avoir
confiance en personne
vous comprenez
sujet qui envoie les décharges il est
bien conscient que ce qu'il fait n'est
pas normal
il est bien conscient que ça ne se fait
pas et pourtant il est en train de le
faire
bien qu'il ya une raison
qu'il y ait une explication
si le sujet ne voit pas l'explication
même s'il persiste à trouver ça anormal
il a en lui une confiance dans les
structures de la société tels qu'ils ne
peux pas croire qu'on lui demande de
commettre un acte répréhensible
un acte condamnable sur le plan moral
alors vous allez me dire c'est une
conception bien naïve comment croire que
des représentants de l'autorité ne
puisse pas nous demander de faire
quelque chose d' illégitime
bien sûr que c'est naïf
sûr que ça participe d'une vision
angélistes de la société
on est bien d'accord
il faut bien aussi tuer que pour la
plupart des gens nous vivons dans une
société qui fonctionne selon des règles
et des principes une société bâtie sur
des structures parmi lesquels la
confiance
sans confiance pas de vie sociale
possible je ne parle pas de la confiance
qui consiste à laisser sa porte ouverte
contre on part travailler ou à laisser
ses clés de voiture sur le contact
on parle de la confiance qui fait que
quand vous allez chercher votre baguette
chez le boulanger vous ne présuppose et
pas que votre baguette est empoisonné
on parle de la confiance qui fait que
vous ne soupçonnez pas votre facteur de
lire votre courrier
c'est cette confiance là qu'on parle
la confiance comme condition de
possibilité de la coexistence sociale
et le fait de ne pas prendre en compte
cette dimension de la confiance
nécessaire à la coexistence sociale
le fait de penser qu'il serait anormal
d'obéir à une demande émanant d'une
autorité perçu comme légitime
c'est ça qui est naïf
parce que saigner l'idée que l'individu
n'a pas une autonomie absolue
une autonomie morale absolue
certains d'entre vous doivent connaître
les caméras cachées de françois damiens
et que fait françois damiens dans ces
caméras cachées et la plupart du temps
il joue le rôle d'un agent social auquel
on accorde spontanément notre confiance
il va jouer le rôle d'un guichetier à la
poste va jouer le rôle d'un vendeur de
chaussures ou d'un réceptionniste
c'est à dire qu'il va jouer le rôle d'un
individu qui s'insère dans une structure
sociale
et donc quand il s'amuse à faire répéter
25 fois la même chose à un usager bien
l'usagé de bonne foi il va lui répéter
25 fois la même chose
et l'usager va bien entendu se rendre
compte qu'un problème s'en rendre compte
que la situation n'est pas tout à fait
normal
et pourtant il va malgré tout accepté
malgré tout joué le jeu joué le jeu de
la confiance sociale et l'être humain
est très fort quand il s'agit de croire
dans des raisons qui l'ignorent
être main très fort quand il s'agit
d'accepter de ne pas comprendre dans une
situation qui sort totalement des règles
conventionnelles
des règles qu'on s'attend à voir
appliquer dans la société
l'individu se dira si on sent des
conventions c'est qu'il ya une raison
je ne peux pas croire dans l'idée que
les structures sociales ne tiennent plus
donc j'accepte
j'obéis parce qu'il doit bien y avoir
une raison
cette attitude qui consiste à se rendre
compte que quelque chose n'est pas
normal mais à l'accepter au nom de la
confiance dans les structures sociales
c'est ce que j'appellerais un conflit
des paradigmes le conflit entre notre
représentation des structures sociales
et la réalité de la situation à laquelle
on fait face
et ce conflit peut conduire le sujet à
prendre le parti de la confiance dans
les structures de la société
et d'ailleurs appelé vous on disait que
le taux d'obéissance des sujets de
l'expérience de milgram tombé à zéro
pour cent quand le sujet percevez une
des cohérences de l'autorité c'est à
dire lorsque deux représentants de
l'autorité et met un désaccord et ça ça
confirme tout ce qu'on vient de dire
c'est à dire que quand françois damiens
joue le rôle d'un guichetier à la poste
et qu'il persécute un pauvre usagers là
il suffit que directeur de la poste
arrive et qui demande à françois damiens
que c'est que ce bordel qu'il demande à
quoi ils jouent à ce moment là vous
pouvez être certain que l'usager va se
rebeller
parce que la décohérence de l'autorité à
laquelle il sera en train d'assister ce
sera pour lui le feu vert à la
désobéissance
le feu vert à l'expression de son
autonomie moral
juger celui qui obéit et le qualifié de
sous c'est oublier un peu vite que nous
obéissons tous à des autorités
nous passons notre vie obéir
les employés obéissent à leurs patrons
le contribuable obéit au fisc
le soldat au colonel
bien rares sont ceux qui peuvent se
prévaloir de n'obéir à aucune autorité
et d'ailleurs remarquer que le jugement
que l'on porte sur ceux qui obéissent à
l'autorité curieusement on oublie de le
porter dans les situations où nous
sommes nous même en situation
d'obéissance
la question serait plutôt de savoir à
quoi obéit ton
est ce que c'est qu'une guerre
une guerre c'est une soumission massive
à une autorité
une guerre ça consiste à aller tué sur
ordre
tuer des personnes qu'on ne connaît pas
et de faire sans qu'on nous pose la
question de savoir si on trouve ça
légitime ou pas
et pourtant nous célébrons les héros de
guerre comme des modèles de courage
le problème n'est pas tant l'obéissance
que l'obéissance aveugle l'obéissance
aveugle c'est l'obéissance qui nous fait
abandonner notre discernement c'est
l'obéissance que nous ne remettons pas
en cause
c'est l'obéissance comme habitude comme
habitude sociale
et finalement on peut trouver beaucoup
plus de choses à reprocher au
conformisme social c'est-à-dire à la
soumission libre et consentie à des
normes à des codes que nous ne remettons
absolument pas en cause au quotidien
comme la soumission à la mode comme la
soumission à l'idéologie dominante
cette soumission du quotidien qui nous
rend aveugle à l'abandon notre
discernement
à l'abandon de notre libre arbitre le
conformisme social est d'autant plus
problématique qui n'est pas perçu de
manière consciente
contrairement à l'obéissance à une
autorité qui elle est consciente
dans le cas de l'obéissance à une
autorité un conflit des paradigmes
s'engage accompli des valeurs et des
représentations traverse l'individu
il est face à un dilemme
mais il a au moins conscience d'être
face à un dilemme
c'est parce que le conformisme social
est inconscient il n'est pas perçu comme
dangereux qu'il est d'autant plus
dangereux
parce qu'à travers le conformisme social
on abandonne notre capacité
d'insurrection
en 1961 s'est tenu le procès d'adolph
eichmann eichmann était un haut
fonctionnaire du troisième reich
il était responsable de la logistique de
la solution finale
après avoir échappé au procès de
nuremberg il a été retrouvé
capturé est condamné à mort à l'issue
d'un procès à jérusalem et la philosophe
hannah arendt s'est intéressé à son cas
s'est intéressé à son procès dont elle a
fait un compte-rendu un compte-rendu
dont une phrase est restée célèbre
une phrase dans laquelle ana rentes
évoque la banalité du mal
ce que cette expression signifiait et
c'est ce que dira hannah arendt et qui
d'ailleurs lui vaudra de très nombreux
reproches c'est le fait qu'elle ait dit
que le comportement d' iceman se
rapprochait davantage d'un comportement
bureaucrates que d'un comportement
criminel
autrement dit iceman n'ayant pas été au
contact des conséquences de ses
décisions
il n'a à aucun moment eu le sentiment
d'agir en criminels de guerre
le phénomène qui est à l'oeuvre dans
l'expérience de milgram et dans cette
soumission à l'autorité légitime
c'est un phénomène de délégation de la
responsabilité
et la délégation la responsabilité c'est
lorsqu'on abandonne son autorité morale
au profit d'une autorité qui prend en
charge les conséquences de nos actes
la délégation de la responsabilité c'est
le fait de se dire qu'on est couvert et
donc lorsqu'on agit là d'une certaine
manière ce n'est pas nous qui agissons
c'est l'autorité qui agit à travers nous
et c'est ainsi que la responsabilité se
reportent se dilue et donc en quelque
sorte réduit la pression qu'elle exerce
sur la conscience de l'individu
alors j'ajouterai simplement pour
terminer cette analyse que les résultats
obtenus par milgram ont été contestés
par une philosophe australienne du nom
de gina perry qui a publié un livre en
2013 dans lequel elle accuse milgram
d'avoir manipulé les résultats de son
étude
alors parmi les aspects qu'elle conteste
elle écrit notamment que en réalité ce
ne serait pas 65 % des sujets qui aurait
obéi mais moins de la moitié moins 50%
et ça évidemment ça change la donne en
tout cas symboliquement ce n'est pas la
même chose de dire que la majorité des
individus obéissent à l'autorité que de
dire que c'est en fait moins de la
moitié
parce qu'évidemment si c'est la majorité
des individus qui obéissent on est en
droit de conclure que c'est l'être
humain lui-même qui se soumet à
l'autorité
lorsqu'une majorité d'individus sont
concernés par un phénomène et devient
beaucoup plus facile et beaucoup plus
tentant de généraliser cette majorité à
l'ensemble des individus
la deuxième chose que conteste jean a
péri c'est le fait qu'il y aurait eu
dans la série d'expériences ponts ont
été menées des infractions au protocole
on avait tout à l'heure que face aux
réticences du sujet évalué face aux
réticences du professeur le scientifique
devait prononcer quatre phrases et à
chaque nouvelle phrase l'injonction se
faisait un peu plus pressante
ce que nous dit jean ap rim c'est qu'il
est arrivé que le scientifique aille
jusqu'à demander 26 fois au sujet de
poursuivre l'expérience 26 fois au lieu
des 4 qui était prévu dans le protocole
donc évidemment ça ne remet pas en cause
le fait que le sujet a fini par obéir
mais ça relativise l'idée selon laquelle
il n'en faudrait pas beaucoup pour faire
obéir le sujet encore ça change un petit
peu la donne sur l'idée assez répandue
selon laquelle l'expérience de milgram
démontrerait une sorte de soumission
automatique et aveugle à l'autorité
et enfin le troisième aspect qui est
reproché à 1000 g c'est le fait il y
aurait chez lui dès le début un biais de
confirmation
c'est à dire que milgram n'aurait pas
organisé cette expérience de manière
totalement innocentes mais qu'il avait
déjà une certaine idée du résultat qu'il
souhaitait obtenir autrement dit que
milgram voulait prouver que l'être
humain a tendance à se soumettre à
l'autorité
et ça c'est quelque chose qui sur le
plan de la méthodologie scientifique
pose de très gros problèmes parce
qu'évidemment l'intention du
scientifique qui organise une expérience
de ce type est ça révèle qu'il a un
intérêt à obtenir certains résultats
plutôt que d'autres
autrement dit ça pourrait expliquer en
partie le fait que le pourcentage de
sujets qui obéissent aurait été
augmentée le fait que des infractions
protocole et puis être commises
l'expérience de milgram nous apprend
quelque chose c'est d'abord la
formidable complexité de la conscience
morale humaine
une conscience morale qu'on a souvent
tendance à placer dans des situations
manichéenne
des situations où ce qu'ils
s'opposeraient ce serait le bien contre
le mal
ce serait les gentils contre les
méchants
si le jugement moral à l'égard des
sujets obéissant à l'autorité me paraît
pour le moins malvenue c'est lié au fait
que ça participe de cet oubli général de
cette inconscience général
de notre propre part sombre
de notre propre côté obscur
qui fait qu on s'érige d'autant plus
comme les représentants du bien les
représentants de la bonne conscience
qu'on n'a pas eu à subir l'expérience du
conflit moral
subir l'expérience du conflit moral subi
à l'expérience du dilemme c'est quelque
chose qui nous prémunit contre le
jugement
c'est quelque chose qui nous portent
davantage à essayer de comprendre qu'à
vouloir juger
s'ériger en puzzle des consciences qui
nous indique qu'elle porte nous méritons
la porte de l'approbation ou la porte de
la condamnation
rousseau disait que
l'état social
citoyen obéissent à des lois
ils obéissent aux lois mais n'obéissent
qu'aux lois et c'est parce qu'ils
obéissent aux lois qui n'obéissent pas
aux hommes
en obéissant à une loi
il pas un homme
on obéit à un principe
un principe un personnel
sip
choisir
choisir que nous devons faire les
preuves du déchirement de la conscience
mais la responsabilité
obéir aux hommes c'est obéir à des êtres
corruptible
obéir à des idées
à des valeurs à des principes
et obéir à soi même
c'est choisir sans juger c'est choisir
et assumé je vous remercie
[Musique]